hola bienvenidos aquí a américa el
magazine de france 24 para conocer en
profundidad las noticias y las historias
de nuestro continente yo soy natalia
cabrera y esto es lo que veremos hoy en
una cachetada a los partidos
tradicionales la mayoría de los
colombianos decidió llevar a una segunda
vuelta de las elecciones presidenciales
al izquierdista gustavo petro y al
candidato que se presentó como
independiente de rodolfo hernández les
entregamos el contexto
y en su esfuerzo para cumplir su meta de
reducir la criminalidad el régimen de
nadie bukele está cometiendo un crimen
al encarcelar a miles de personas
arbitrariamente nos llevamos a el
salvador
y visitamos méxico donde un grupo de
científicos busca una solución para
repoblar los mares con el pepino de mar
que está desapareciendo por su alto
precio en asia
y vamos de inmediato a colombia para
nuestra historia principal en un claro
mensaje de los votantes a la clase
política tradicional los ciudadanos
decidieron que gustavo petro del pacto
histórico de izquierda se enfrentará a
rodolfo hernández aspirante de la
nombrada como liga de gobernantes
anticorrupción en la segunda vuelta de
las elecciones presidenciales que tendrá
lugar el 19 de junio el candidato que
representaba a la derecha y era apoyado
por los partidos políticos tradicionales
federico gutiérrez quedó en tercer lugar
con un importante 23 por ciento de los
votos por lo que su apoyo a alguno de
ellos puede determinar quién llegará a
la casa de nariño en las próximas tres
semanas se prevé una intensa campaña en
la que tanto petro como hernández
buscarán sumar apoyos
y en una colombia altamente polarizada
la figura de petro genera amores y odios
el ex integrante de la extinta guerrilla
del m-19 ex alcalde de bogotá y
aspirante a la presidencia en dos
oportunidades previas ha anunciado que
restablecería las relaciones
diplomáticas con venezuela rotas porque
el gobierno de iván duque de derecha no
reconoce a nicolás maduro como
presidente legítimo este es un tema
espinoso para algunos colombianos y en
general para algunos ciudadanos que
habitan los países vecinos de venezuela
como perú donde también en campaña se
asociaba al presidente pedro castillo
con el chavismo los ciudadanos de estos
países tras haber visto la masiva
migración causada por la crisis en el
país petrolero asocian una cercanía
ideológica con el chavismo con una de
bajo un equipo de france 24 acompañó a
petro a su pueblo natal ciénaga de oro
para mostrarnos el fenómeno que
despierta a su paso
[Música]
no es una estrella del rock es gustavo
petro quieres ser presidente de colombia
el evento se llama petro escucha los
asistentes le plantean propuestas
tomando mate en grande lo tengo en
frente de la
[Música]
ciénaga de oro es un municipio cerca del
mar caribe ilusiona la posibilidad de
tener el primer presidente del
departamento de córdoba
los orígenes de gustavo petro son
mientras llegan como amigos sus primos
enseñan la casa en la que nació hoy es
la sede del partido el era de pocas
palabras muy tímido pero las pocas
conversaciones que forjaba con uno tenía
esa orientación de líder
es probable que contenga algunas en la
zona también quedan viejos compañeros de
lucha vaché rodríguez perteneció la
extinta guerrilla del m-19 a la que
petro se incorporó en 1977 se
desmovilizaron en 1990 tras un acuerdo
de paz petro representa los valores del
m-19 expresado en
paz
justicia trabajo y democracia hoy
tuviera 60 años de edad pero más de 30
años después muchos no olvidan su pasado
gustavo laca es médico y fue alcalde de
ciénaga de oro en dos ocasiones
matar
a su hermano lo mató el m-19 y los
criminales no son ex criminales
los criminales háganse siempre
criminales gustavo petro acaba la
jornada con un mitin y
rodeado de seguridad y acompañado por
miles de fieles pretende romper con la
historia para convertirse en el primer
presidente de izquierda de colombia
el candidato rodolfo hernández es una
sorpresa para muchos este político de 77
años asegura tener una fortuna de más de
100 millones de dólares y se presentó
como el aspirante antisistema sus
polémicas declaraciones entre las que
están la admiración por las políticas de
hitler y comentarios misóginos le han
valido el título del trump colombiano
se llama a sí mismo ingeniero rodolfo
hernández y se autodefine como out sider
del mundo de la política natural del
departamento de santander al noreste de
colombia hernández creció en el seno de
una familia liberal y siguiendo el
consejo de su abuela trabaje con los
pobres y se hará rico consiguió amasar
una fortuna en el mundo de la
construcción como ingeniero civil y
empresario su carrera despegó en 2015
cuando fue elegido alcalde de la capital
de santander o bucaramanga desde
entonces sus bases políticas son las
mismas lucha contra la corrupción la que
llama buena administración del dinero
público y cero impunidad con los
criminales y convencimiento de llegar
hasta los más vulnerables con un
discurso y políticas fuertemente
populistas
un compromiso que los colombianos más
pobres
tengan un mejor vivir
muchos lo definen como el donald trump
colombiano que entró en el mundo de la
política como multimillonario y se
presentó como la opción anti
establishment aunque se han probado sus
nexos con políticos tradicionales y
otras polémicas como la filtración de
sus amenazas a un cliente de su
constructora por teléfono o un entramado
de corrupción el vita logic en el que se
le acusa de conceder un contrato público
supuestamente a dedo acusaciones que
siempre ha negado presentándose incluso
como puro
de m
a pesar de sus 77 años hernández logra
llegar hasta sus seguidores a través de
redes sociales conocido como el viejito
rey del dicto
fácil
en forma
por bus desde donde pide a la población
que se suba a la rodolfo nita y vote por
él
esta inédita segunda vuelta da cuenta
del hartazgo ciudadano con la clase
política que tradicionalmente gobierna
colombia pues ambos candidatos se
presentan a sí mismos como fuera de las
maquinarias políticas le preguntamos al
analista internacional mauricio
jaramillo si tanto petro como hernández
pueden ser considerados populistas y
esto fue lo que nos dijo la diferencia
fundamental me parece que en el caso de
error fue hernández espacio un demagogo
de derecha que se aprovecha de la
incorrección política tal como tú lo
decías como en el caso de versionar o
bien donald trump cuando uno ve lo que
dice la migración cuando no ve lo que
dice los derechos humanos de la
corrupción se parece mucho pero si es un
populista en un movimiento de masas que
tiene una trayectoria además en política
pero no entra del todo en el discurso
anti establecimiento porque nos manda
nos ha sido concejal
congresista alcalde bogotá jefe de la
oposición
se trata de dos anti establecimientos
muy distintos uno populista y otro
demagogo cambiamos de tema y nos vamos a
elsalvador más de 30.000 personas han
sido asesinadas bajo el estado de
excepción decretado por el presidente
salvadoreño nadie bukele en febrero bajo
el argumento de luchar contra el
incremento en la tasa de homicidios no
obstante organizaciones defensoras de
los derechos humanos denuncian que
algunas de ellas no están justificadas y
que muchos no son pandilleros o mareros
como se les conoce en el país el informe
es de nuestro corresponsal vladimir
tovar
marta morales de 70 años ha recorrido
las cárceles durante días buscando a
tres de sus familiares que fueron
detenidos en medio del estado de
excepción declarado por el gobierno
salvadoreño a finales del mes de marzo
mire yo lo que más quisiera desde que
estas cosas llegarán a nuestro señor
presidente porque él ha ordenado que se
capturen a los delincuentes no a las
personas civiles
y yo siento que van parejo o sea no
entiendo por qué capturan a las personas
que no tienen nada que ver con cosas
delictivas
si bien el gobierno asegura que las
capturas son de integrantes de pandillas
organizaciones de derechos humanos
reportan centenares de arrestos
arbitrarios los familiares de los
detenidos confirman que los arrestos son
sin orden judicial y sin investigación
las autoridades de seguridad han
reconocido la muerte de 11 personas bajo
custodia penitenciaria entre ellos el de
william galeas
la última vez que lo vi fue ese día por
la mañana y casi un mes después lo veo
pero no en las condiciones que yo quería
no es parte del alma toda la familia
del otro lado de la ciudad víctor su
nigga no tiene tiempo para ir a
preguntar por su pareja arrestada a
inicios de mayo ya que tiene que
trabajar y cuidar a la hija de ambos de
apenas nueve meses
de dolor
porque la gente la escucha y oral
pero no lloro de dolor sino que de
angustia por el olor a madre por el
sentimiento de la madre
el temor de víctor es no volver a ver a
su compañera el de los defensores de
derechos humanos es que la
transgresiones se vuelva una situación
permanente mientras el gobierno celebra
la efectividad de las medidas especiales
que fueron extendidas por otros 30 días
cada vez son más las personas que
abarrotan las afueras de las cárceles en
búsqueda de sus familiares detenidos
vamos a méxico donde un grupo de
científicos busca repoblar el océano de
pepino de mar una de las especies que de
manera natural le ayuda a limpiar las
aguas la especie está en peligro debido
a su alta demanda en el mercado asiático
lo que ha llevado a la pesca furtiva e
indiscriminada nuestros corresponsales
en la península de yucatán nos traen la
historia
estas criaturas marinas son un limpiador
natural de los océanos pero su alta
demanda en el mercado asiático en las
últimas dos décadas provocó su
sobrepesca a nivel mundial y ahora son
especies en extinción las poblaciones
silvestres empiezan a verse agotadas
disminuidas de tal a tal grado que
actualmente es a partir de 2019 se
decreta una veda total para la captura
de pepino de mar y entonces ahorita el
objetivo del gobierno ya no es instalar
granjas sino que se produzcan crías para
que se haga una repoblación en la
península de yucatán en el sureste de
méxico investigadores se producen y
cultivan el pepino de mar en este
laboratorio no se trata de restaurar las
poblaciones que han sido afectadas por
la sobrepesca
a través de la liberación de juveniles
producidos en cautiverio eso sería más o
menos la idea de este proyecto en asia
se cree que el pepino de mar tiene
cualidades curativas
medicinales y afrodisíacas en la
gastronomía china es uno de los manjares
más cotizados su valor puede superar los
dos mil dólares y esto provocó la pesca
furtiva y depredación
[Música]
el pepino de marzo sobre explotó y
podría pasar hasta cinco décadas para
que logre recuperarse de forma natural
de ahí la importancia de acelerar su
reproducción
para después de un par de meses en el
laboratorio en las mejores situaciones
hemos tenido animales lo suficientemente
grandes para poder trasladarlos
nuevamente al mar los investigadores van
por la reproducción a gran escala
aspiran a restaurar zonas impactadas y
crear granjas de cultivos en zonas
controladas que permitan que esta
pesquería vuelva a ser una importante
fuente de ingreso para los pescadores
pero sin dañar el ecosistema
gracias por acompañarnos sigan viendo
france24
[Música]
era muy bienvenidos al antro